-Our next guest is a talented
singer and song writer
you know from
both his solo career
and work with One Direction.
His third solo album "The Show"
will be out June and is
available for preorder now.
He will also be a coach on the
new season of "The Voice,"
which premieres March 6th
at 8:00 PM here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-I nearly hit my button
on your first note.
-Long enough for me to actually
figure it out before him.
-Please, Kelly, come on.
Give me a chance.
You remind me so much of
my good friend Maren Morris.
-Oh, my gosh.
-I've spent a lot of time
on the stage over the years
and become very, very, very
fond of country music,
and country always
leads into story telling,
and I tend to do that.
Your voice, the control,
it was just unbelievable.
I'm telling you,
we're going to do big things
together if you come with me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please!
-Please welcome to the show
Niall Horan, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy you're here,
my friend.
-I'm happy to be here.
Huge fan of the show.
-We were very lucky to --
I was very lucky, I should say,
to work with you 10 years ago.
You fellas were on the show,
and we did a sketch.
I was on set for where Paul Rudd
was the number one.
There we see Paul.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I have spoken
for years about
how you were
the nicest group of guys.
And, I mean, you were
fairly young at the time.
Was that an exciting thing
to do?
-Oh, yeah.
It was crazy to be part of "SNL"
on a few occasions is so cool.
But that particular weekend
Paul was hosting the show.
And the "Anchorman" crew
were there.
-Yeah.
-They were promoting
"Anchorman 2."
-You got to sing with the --
and this is two of the great
casts of all time.
-"Anchorman"
being like, no joke,
my favorite movie of all time.
And just be standing there
singing "Afternoon Delight"
with that bunch of lunatics
was pretty special.
-Yeah.
The other funny thing about
the sketch with Paul I remember
we had a great many extras
who also
were big One Direction fans.
And it was the least we ever had
to give direction
to a group of young girls.
-"Applause. Applause. Applause."
They were already screaming.
-"When they walk out,
like, lose your minds."
They were like,
"I think we can do that."
-Yeah, yeah.
"We can sort that out."
-This is very exciting.
You have a new single out.
-Yes, I do.
-You have a new album coming.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-I think a lot of people --
you know, a lot of artists
reacted different ways
to the pandemic
and what it put them through.
-Yeah.
-Did you feel like you wanted to
start working on new music
right away?
Did you give yourself
a little time?
Because it's been a while since
you -- about three years?
-Yeah, exactly.
No, I kind of --
I released an album
the day we were told we were
going into lockdown.
Some would say
that was great timing.
[ Laughs ]
No, but it was
one of those things
where I release an album
and then that happened.
And then the tour got cancelled.
So I was thinking like...
I was kind of just angry
at the world, like we all were.
-Yeah.
-So, then I was sitting around,
waiting for something to happen,
waiting for
the creative juices to flow.
Took a while.
And then once it came,
it kind of --
it opened the door for what is
now a finished product, record.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Very exciting.
I wonder, do you --
I mean, obviously
you work on these songs
and a lot of
post production on the music
and finally get it to a place
where you're happy with it.
And then it gets
released to the world.
Are you someone who --
Do you sort of anticipate
the reaction to it?
Have you already moved on
to the next?
-No, I'm just always so nervous.
Like, it's the biggest cliche.
When ever you work on something,
you just obviously want it
to do well.
But we have no idea.
Especially these days,
it's hard to know --
it's so competitive out there.
But I've got --
as you can hear, I have --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm lucky enough to have
a strong, solid fan base.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Having said that -- Having said
that, you still don't know.
So I'm just, like, after three
years of not releasing music,
there's that, like,
"Please do good."
-Yeah.
-But the reaction to
this single first of all
has been ridiculous,
which makes me feel
a lot better about the record.
-Well, there you go.
Very exciting.
And now this is really exciting,
'cause you talked about
your last tour being cancelled.
You're going on the road
this summer
and you're doing
a great many festivals,
which is different that
sort of doing more
sort of conventional tour.
Are you excited about
festival life?
-I think that is the main thing
I wanted to do
when I was finishing off
the record.
I said to everyone, like,
"I would love to just do
a summer of festivals,"
especially having spent
so much time away.
It's good to get back
in front of people in that way.
You know, I can go
all over the world,
and we're doing them
all over Europe and Japan
and a couple here in the states.
And, like, it's just going to be
good to feel the love.
And I'm a huge festival goer
myself.
I've been that drunk guy...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-...standing in my welly boots
in a field going,
"Who's that up there?
I like the sound of that."
So I want --
That's why I wanted to do it.
I can get some new fans here,
Seth.
-Well, absolutely.
This speaks to the level
of difficulty of a festival.
Because obviously, you know,
you have a group of people
who are all music fans.
-Mm-hmm.
-But, you know, specifically
they might be less there
to see you.
Like, they might be there
to see the person before you
or after you,
so you do have to win them over.
And I think
it's really impressive that
you want to take on
that challenge.
-Oh, for sure.
-You don't necessarily have to,
but I think that will be
so exciting.
-No, it's a great way
of getting, like, new people.
As you say, there's a solid
group there, but it's --
You know, I'd love to invite
more people into the world.
-Do you feel like you get to
meet and hang out
with other bands
in the festival world?
Is that one of the up sides?
-Yeah, no. They're always good.
You meet people
that you have no idea
you had anything in common with,
And before you know it's 2:00.
[ Laughs ]
It's been a good night.
-Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
And Europe,
is it buses around Europe
when you're doing...?
-Yeah. There's a lot of --
Because they're so far apart,
other countries, you do have to
do a lot of flying.
When we're in the states,
it's a lot of buses.
-Do you enjoy -- Is bus life --
Because I feel there's something
a little romantic about it
maybe for the first three days.
-Yeah, exactly.
You're like,
you've seen "Spinal Tap" twice
and now you think
"Yeah, that's how it's done."
[ Laughs ]
Then it's like 105 degrees
in Houston, Texas.
First week of July,
and it's sweaty
and you've woken up and
air-conditioning is broken.
It's just like, "Maybe not as
romantic as I thought."
[ Laughter ]
-Um, one place that's very well
air-conditioned,
I've heard, is this studio
for "The Voice."
Congratulations on that gig.
-It's Baltic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is this --
How did this come to pass?
I'm assuming this is a situation
where your phone just rang
one day and they reached out?
-Literally. Phone call from
the producers, Audrey, Kyra.
And they just said,
"Before you even say anything,
just come in and meet us."
And they explained
how the show works
and all that good stuff.
And I was like,
"Yeah, let's just give it a go.
See what happens."
I've been on a show like that.
-Of course, yeah.
-So, I un-- I do...
I understand --
I understand how it works.
But, yeah,
it was just a challenge,
something that
I wasn't expecting.
-Right.
-You know, a great time to do it
before I've got
a record coming out.
And you're going to be
sick of my faces.
Or sick of my face.
But, yeah, no,
it's been so fun.
We were very lucky with the crew
of coaches that I'm with.
-Yeah.
-It could've been horrific.
You know, you're sitting there
every night pretending that
you like the person
you're sat next to.
I got very lucky
in Blake Shelton alone.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Now, I would imagine too
having gone through a show
like this, you must have --
because obviously
it looks very exciting
what we see on television.
But you obviously are in this
situation you can have empathy
with them
for what they're going through.
Because I think we all maybe
forget how stressful it is
for an unknown artist to --
especially in a room like that
to be in front of
four very accomplished,
very famous singers.
-Yeah.
-They must feel nice knowing
and being like, "Oh, I know
Niall has been on this side."
-Whoo!
-I guess that's a part --
Ooh, That was a big one.
[ Laughter ]
No, it is -- It's good...
I think that's
how I got half of my team
because they understand that
I've got that empathy with them.
I was -- You know,
17-, 18-, 19-year-old people
coming on here,
and I was that 16-year-old
just kind of knowing
that person there
has got my future
in their hands.
And it's -- That's the hardest
thing about "The Voice."
It's like I have to make
in-game decisions
over two singers that
are standing in front of me...
knowing that I have
their future in my hands.
And that's the part that I feel
like the empathy side of me.
I hope I don't lose it,
because I would be heartless
if I did lose that.
-Well, I think if you want to
know what it's like
to be without empathy,
that feels like probably what
Blake Shelton does, right?
-Blake Shelton. There you go.
After 12 years...
12 years and 23 seasons.
-Yeah.
-He's stone cold, that man.
-He's stone cold. A man
who this is his last season.
Obviously he's done a great
amount of success on the show.
When ever he's here,
he is not shy about
bragging about his success.
Has he been giving you
a hard time?
Because he also seems
very good at that.
-That's all he does anywhere, to
everyone that will listen to him
or don't want to listen to him.
-[ Laughs ]
-He's just constantly
just nailing everyone.
-He's a very charismatic
and affable bully.
-Yeah. [ Chuckles ] Correct.
That's exactly what he is.
But he's an absolute beauty.
And, you know, he's going
to be missed around that show.
Like, he is "The Voice" --
probably in his head, too.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But he's so good to work with.
And, yeah, he'll be missed
around there for sure.
-I mean, yeah, I think one of
the reasons the show
is so exceptional
is the connection
you guys all have together
and the chemistry.
Do you feel like --
When he leaves,
do you feel like you'll have
a good Blake Shelton impression?
Do you have one yet?
-[ As Blake ] I'm Blake Shelton.
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
This is my...
[ Normal voice ] I feel like a
politician every time I do it.
[ Blake ] This is my last season
on "The Voice,"
and I would love if you would be
on the last-ever Team Blake.
[ Normal voice ] And he says
that to every single person
who comes out --
win, lose or draw.
-I will tell you, I know you
said you felt like a politician,
but you said that
and looked at me,
I was like,
"I want to be on Team Blake."
It totally worked.
It was very convincing.
-I need a catch phrase.
-You've got to work on it.
Hey, man, what a pleasure
to have you here.
I really can't thank you enough.
And congratulations
on the new music.
Niall Horan.
His new album
"The Show"
is available for preorder now,
and "The Voice" premieres
March 6th at 8:00 PM
right here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."